over the last decade the 3130 has
obviously evolved i mean
in the beginning uh i mean my key role
was really just kicking off the idea and
putting in motion but it really involves
at this point the entire forbes
organization we literally have hundreds
of people
who work on this every single one of the
lists and we have 20 lists for 30 to 30
it's not
one list as everybody knows if you
expand out past just the staff
we literally have judges and and experts
who are making nominations
we're literally talking about hundreds
of people who are going into this so it
really is a team effort
and the results show
the forbes under 30 list is all about
highlighting individuals that bring a
fresh perspective to old paradigms
this is my third time producing our
largest under 30 list
north america which is now in its 10th
year but this year was unlike
anything we've done before the pandemic
put every aspect of the project in
question
would coven 19 tank the startup
ecosystem to the point that we couldn't
find qualified candidates
would we be able to safely produce the
photoshoots and videos that make the
under 30 magazine so iconic every year
and in a pandemic world with so many
people suffering wasn't even the right
thing to do
to highlight individuals that are
succeeding right now this this 10th
annual list
is special a lot of ways i mean i think
this year did
throw a lot of curveballs our way there
are obviously entire industries that are
really hurting right now
i mean let's say you know i was a judge
uh in the
in the in the food and drink category
and you just don't have restaurants
opening but again
we found people who are creating apps
that helped restaurants
stay in business or be able to deliver
more officially we found people who were
taking advantage of the people the fact
that people were cooking more so that's
that's an example of having to think
differently the world
was different this year but we found
people achieving uh
in their industries uh despite the
differences or maybe because of those
differences
it's a really amazing list in a very
difficult challenging year but there's a
lot of optimism here because you see
people who are doing such incredible
things and again building bridges that
are going to make
the post pandemic period uh even better
to get on the 30 under 30 we're looking
for people who are entrepreneurial we're
looking for change agents and change
makers we're looking for people
who are not content just to achieve but
to
push the world forward to change the
world and change their field in a
positive way
the 30-30 has always been an incredibly
diverse list it's a it's a list
you know i used to say it's a list that
today looks like america
american leadership will look but
increasingly as america continues to
progress i mean the 30-30 is reflecting
that
and that we are taking great steps to
source beyond the usual places to find
people who have not been kind of
quote-unquote discovered before at least
the world hasn't heard about them
and to make sure that again this list
continues
to be a true meritocracy and be a list
that looks
like america looks today
you